dieu je prie pour que ce soit une
session très productives et que vous
retrouviez tous la flamme pour pouvoir
toujours faire super bien l'amour ici à
même fils du est beaucoup moins
pudibonds l'une des nouvelles tendances
de l'église protestante américaine s'est
en effet le séminaire spécial sexe avec
au micro dans le rôle de conseiller
intime
le pasteur stacy spencer et sa femme
pour bien prendre son pied il faut lui
montrer que vous l'aimez pas juste lui
dire vous voulez vraiment savoir comment
chauffer votre femme alors fait la
vaisselle mon frère et attendez je me
l'appliqué à moi-même et pour embraser
son public
le ministre de dieu n'est pas vraiment
aucun détail il existe sans une position
sexuelle différent il y a plein de zones
érogènes dans le corps par exemple si le
clitoris et sa zone érogène et si au
lieu de l'embrasser de lui tenir la main
de lui caresser les cheveux ou sautées
au lit et vous fera
c'est cru ces caches et ça marche depuis
que le pasteur spencer parle de sexe à
l'église il est devenu une sorte de
gourou
[Applaudissements]
félicitations
un bébé en route c'est génial dieu te
bénisse même fils c'est la capitale de
la culture noire sa population est
composée à 60% d'afro américains c'est
la patrie du blues et la ville natale
d'elvis presley et c'est surtout un
grand supermarché de la religion la
ville compte plus de 2000 églises
différentes de la plus conservatrice à
la plus progressiste alors à memphis
pour draguer le fidèle le pasteur
spencer à dénicher le bon filon à la
tête de son église depuis sept ans il
eut la révélation voilà quelques mois
enseigner à ses fidèles tous les bons
tuyaux pour s'éclater au lit je voyais
mes fidèles divorcés se séparer alors
j'ai dit stop il faut les aider à
ramener l'amour et le sexe dans leur
mariage ce qui reste péché pour moi
c'est l'adultère la pornographie est
parti à plusieurs comme vous dites en
français le ménage à trois et
l'homosexualité
je crois que le mariage ça doit se
passer entre un mari et sa femme en un
an à peine ils sont devenus les nouveaux
sexologue de même fils et leurs méthodes
40 nuits de super sexe se révèle être un
filon miraculeux dans l'église du
pasteur spencer on peut à la fois à
prier et faire du shopping
le pasteur a pensé aux produits dérivés
ou sein même de l'église une boutique
vend des dvd des cd et une flopée de
guide
c'est ça notre baisse s'élève à
suprématie du christ aujourd'hui 600
couples sont inscrits au séminaire
enflammée du bon pasteur comme femme et
derek de commerciaux devenus des
disciples modèle désormais à la maison
il se chauffe à coude bible j'ai lécher
mon rayon de miel et moi je vais grimper
sur la montagne de mire
jusqu à l'antre-2 lançant tu es belle ma
chérie
il n'y a pas de défaut en toi homme et
derek en sont à leur troisième séminaire
mariés depuis trois ans ils ont re
découvert avec plaisir les péché de la
chair
[Musique]
bon maintenant on fait l'amour
quatre fois par semaine par semaine à
memphis ton univers impitoyable face à
cette concurrence torride les églises
traditionnelles se vide dans ce bastion
de chrétiens conservateurs parler de
sexe à l'église relèvent du blasphème
c'est complètement déplacé ce genre de
chose doit être fait d'une manière de
descente on ne peut pas en faire une
discussion de caniveau quand même
quelque chose qui est destiné aux
mariages ça croyez moi cette nouvelle
voie c'est vraiment pas le chemin que
dio révolue
à memphis la guerre des églises a
commencé entre les sermons de papa et
les prêches sexy du pasteur spencer les
fidèles semble avoir choisi
[Musique]
oh
vingt-huit personnes sous un même toit
nous sommes chez les hammers une famille
américaine ordinaire
enfin presque j'ai vu quelque part dans
le nouveau testament que jésus s'est
mariée à un endroit appelé canal bruce
est un mari polygame heureux avec ses
trois femmes band a failli et débit il
forme d'un ménage unis ensemble ils
élèvent tout simplement 24 enfants c'est
bruce qui se charge de l'éducation
religieuse
leçon numéro un il forme d'une famille
polygame parce que leur dieu est
polygame qui était dans jésus un
polygame oui il était l'époux alors
qu'ils s'étaient déjà mariés aux noces
de cana il était rabin il devait déjà
avoir des enfants
donc le christ était polygame
[Musique]
aux etats unis la polygamie est
interdite mais ici à montels une petite
ville perdue dans les montagnes de
l'utah
c'est possible et même recommandé si on
veut être un bon bordeaux
fondamentalistes e n'appelle pas ça la
polygamie et préfère dire mariage
pluriel la loi américaine est respectée
seule la première femme et épousé
civilement et les autres religieusement
[Musique]
l'adaptation a été délicate mais sachant
que c'est juste aux yeux de dieu
ça n'a pas été un problème je me suis
fait
et j'aime ces femmes elles sont super
c'est génial d'avoir une super copine
marie avec le même homme mais attention
mariage pluriel ne veut pas dire moeurs
débridées
au contraire les mormons condamne sans
appel l'avortement et toutes les
pratiques sexuelles qui ne serait pas
lié à la reproduction le seul but est
donc la procréation
le principe celui du patriarcat où la
famille est un royaume dont le père
détient l'autorité suprême en principe
[Musique]
c'est lui le patron
oui parfois
mais comment ça parfois j'ai une sorte
de droit de veto comme le président mais
comme lui je peux aussi être destitué
[Musique]
tous
un mari polygame ne s'endort jamais tous
il a une mission sacrée c'est condé ces
femmes doivent savoir en théorie un
enfant parent tant que ça leur est
physiquement possible ce soir bruce n'a
pas encore décidé avec qui ils allaient
passer la nuit
on devient vite prisonnier d'un emploi
du temps sans faire les femmes alors
deviennent pro possessive
elles disent le mardi c'est ma nuit ce
genre de choses j'ai bien essayé
d'organiser un emploi du temps ici mais
en fait je préfère improvisé selon les
envies du moment je ne sais pas où il
dort et je m'en fiche
la polygamie a débarqué en utah avec les
premiers colons normand une pratique
combattu par les autorités américaines
est finalement interdite en 1890 mais
même si désormais tous polygames et
excommunié de l'église mormone officiel
ils n'ont pourtant jamais cessé
d'exister car leur poids économique et
politique locale est réel et les
autorités font preuve d'un zèle assez
modérée pour les traquer il serait donc
aujourd'hui encore près de 100000 en
utah
dans la secte moon
on n'est pas polygame et on se marie en
groupe le plus souvent dans des stades
et par milliers henri blanchard en sait
quelque chose
en 1968 alors qu'il allait devenir
prêtre il fut l'un des premiers français
à s'engager dans cette singulière église
deux ans plus tard il se rend à séoul
pour épouser wild autrichienne moniste
elle aussi il connaît à peine henry mais
accepte le mariage car telle est la
volonté du révérend moon idéale de se
méfier asiatique créé le royaume de dieu
sur terre moyens employés
le mariage pour fonder des milliers de
familles moniste comme henry et ville
pour l'éternité un pas pour quelques
jours vraiment créer une famille
mondiale du sang si on a vraiment le
même idéal on n'a pas chanté des
étrangers jeunes mariés henry s'engage
totalement aux côtés du révérend est de
retour en france il devient président de
l'église de l'unification
le nom officiel de la secte moon
aujourd'hui c'est sous sa direction
qu'un groupe de moniste français
s'embarque vers séoul pour vivre à son
tour la grande aventure du mariage
arrangé du révérend moon
[Musique]
didier maria ou encore pascal son
démoniste convaincu dans quelques jours
ils accompliront leur devoir en épousant
un membre comme eux de l'église de
l'unification et choisis spécialement
par le révérend moon
certaines ont de la chance
elles ont déjà reçu la photo de leur
futur conjoint
si la photo comme un chef
alors va baisser sa nationalité les jo
velly maif et la maaf 82 on lui il a 23
ans et il est étudiant et
bon là j'avais été marié n'a pas
d'enfant j'aurais pu trouver quelqu'un
par moi même mais
finalement chez
vraiment personnellement j'ai une très
grande confiance en ce sens bien
ces choix parce que je pense qu'il a un
très grande capacité de choisir des
personnes qui sont très complémentaires
à notre caractère
d'autres en revanche ne savent pas
encore grand chose de leur future épouse
j'ai pas de trop de renseignements à son
sujet simplement qu'elle s'appelle
messieurs ran et que je suis très
heureux question coréenne parce que
justement j'avais vraiment de plus en
plus dans mon coeur le désir de mettre
la bénédiction de avec une sur séoul
pour accueillir les 80000 frère et soeur
venus cette année se faire bénir par le
révérend l'église alouettes des villages
entiers souvent à plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres de la capitale
ici on dort à 8 par chambre les femmes
d'un côté les hommes de l'autre
périssent ya longtemps prié pour que en
ce monde actuel le monde puisse
rechercher taparole père du ciel pour
revivre vers le ciel vous priez pas
réussir pour cosmo puisque arrêt cet
espoir d'un ciel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant
dans cette maison de séoul moon créé en
1954 la première église du mouvement
après le judaïsme et le christianisme le
messie coréen se dit envoyé par les
cieux jésus est mort dit ils vivent sous
new moon
le vrai père de l'humanité
aujourd'hui son ancien appartement est
devenu un véritable lieu saint du monde
entier les frères et soeurs de la secte
kendy si vénéré leurs vrais parents et
les pièces où ils vécurent
[Musique]
et
derrière le paravent religieux se met en
place la plus extraordinaire
multinationales anticommuniste de
l'après guerre
sur ces images présentées par la secte
moon elle même le révérend tout d'abord
un homme d'affaires puis dans les années
60 il fonde un empire industriel et
commercial basé sur le travail non
rémunéré de ces milliers d'adeptes
[Musique]
au village démoniste c'est ce soir
qu'ont lieu les derniers matching les
couples voulue par le révérend moon sont
appelés sur l'estrade
beaucoup se découvrent pour la première
fois alors on s'observe on s'inquiète un
peu aussi pas si évident de faire la
connaissance de son futur conjoint
devant six ans frère et soeur
surtout quand on ne parle pas toujours
la même langue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce soir certains conjoints choisi par
mots n'ont pas fait le déplacement
il est vrai que ce séjour nuptiale est
facturée 5 à 7000 euros par la sec
sans compter le billet d'avion en cas
d'absence le conjoint le soir c'est une
maigre consolation la photo et le cv de
son prétendant avec l'espoir peut-être
de se retrouver pour la cérémonie
je pense que c'est vraiment très
important tel point que ses débuts d'une
vie éternelle à 12 donc c'est quelque
chose de non jeu j'ai surtout les musset
le jeu vous important qu'il ressent
j'espère qu'elle pourra venir j'espère
il provient autrement je la verrai après
celle ci comment le bâtiment qui sert
également les photos des des soeurs dans
dans ses bras et ensuite ils passent
devant sharp et eric recherche en
personne qui convient mieux en regardant
par exemple les oreilles il peut le
déterminer la meilleure personne qui
commune qui me correspond en bat maria
bien de retrouver marco son futur mari
slovène lors de leur première rencontre
ils se sont demandé non sans un peu
d'appréhension
s'il était vraiment faits l'un pour
l'autre
[Musique]
ça n'a pas été comment dit-on le coup de
foudre mais ça vient plus tard comme ça
vous êtes sûr que votre amour ne démarre
pas très fort pour disparaître très vite
il y attend de divorce aujourd'hui sinon
vous préfère partir de zéro pour que
notre amour augmente comme ça vous
comprenez le lendemain dans le stade de
séoul réservé pour l'occasion c'est le
grand jour
et maintenant salmon drapeau national
didier est un peu triste car les pouces
qu'il est embêtant est resté aux
philippines
et c'est donc seul le sourire un peu
forcé aux lèvres qu'il assistait la
cérémonie et participe bon gré mal gré à
la ferveur discipliné démoniste et la
mise en scène grandiloquente de la
puissance de son révérend formellement à
la volonté des vrais parents promettez
vous de former une famille idéale pour
construire le paradis terrestre
[Applaudissements]
le monde actuel est non seulement un
monde sans espoir mais aussi un monde
influencé par le satan tout puissant et
plein de haine vous tous savaient que
l'histoire humaine est marquée par le
défi de satan pour l'empêcher il faut
liquider totalement les forums et les
fausses vie sur cette terre et
maintenant échanger vos alliances
[Musique]
un moment un peu délicat pour didier
puisque révérend moon ou pas il reste
impossible d'échanger une alliance avec
une photo et maintenant vous êtes unis
par les liens du mariage
à l'issue de cette cérémonie la secte a
revendiqué plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'adhérents de par le monde une
influence difficiles à vérifier la
transparence n'étant pas la spécialité
de la maison moon poursuivi pour fraude
fiscale dans différents pays
ces grandes messes donne en tout cas une
idée de sa capacité à séduire une
planète en quête de sens